[Music]
hi everybody i'm the guest moderator for
film independent and i am so fortunate
to have with us here the director
producer stanley nelson of attica of
course and the co-director and producer
tracy curry welcome and thank you so
much for your
thorough and devastating examination of
one of the shocking and disturbing
incidents in in our nation's history
there was 70
black and brown prisoners all white
guards what could go wrong
grab the guards grab the keys all hell
broke
put your hands in there and you will not
be hired you will not be home you would
not be harmed
but that was brochure
somebody had to take a stand
i want to jump in and just ask you both
initially 63 of the inmates in attica if
i remember correctly are were black and
brown and your film points to sort of
continuous problems with mass
incarceration and the disproportionate
imprisonment of
and mistreatment of black and brown
people um and then of course the abuses
that were rampant in the american prison
system and the desperate need for reform
since this film has come out have you
heard from anybody in law enforcement or
corrections who saw your film and
has any ideas about reform has you know
what have you heard
since this film has its way i personally
haven't heard anything from law
enforcement at all i don't know if tracy
has been no i haven't heard you
um no i haven't but i would certainly
welcome that dialogue if it happened
yeah
i thought it was so powerful the way you
wove in the statements of the of the
prisoners the former prisoners who were
there um and could talk so
still so
you know with so much
visceral memory of it all um
i guess my first question is do you
think something like this could happen
again today 50 years later
um i don't i don't see why
not i mean i think that you know there's
uh over two million people in prison in
the u.s today so
uh and i don't think prison conditions
are that much better um prisons are
still being real
you know and kind of away from the
communities where
so many other people come from um
there's their guards oftentimes still
are
just seen as you know the place to work
in internal living um and there's very
little training so
um i i don't see uh
why something like this
couldn't happen again but tracy what do
you think
yeah i mean it's interesting um that you
asked that claudia because they're
um right now in rikers island um just a
couple miles from where i'm sitting um
there's a pretty horrific situation
that's been um unfolding at the prison
there's horrible overcrowding i'm sorry
it's a jail it's not even a prison so
these people haven't even been um
convicted of any crimes most of them
just can't pay the bail to get out of um
the jail
there's horrible overcrowding they're
images coming out of
dozens of people crammed into a cell
meant for one um there's violence
there's awful conditions there and not
too long ago there was a
group of city elected officials that
toured the prison one of them left and
said this could be another attica um so
i think that pretty clearly uh says that
the answer to that question is yes
absolutely
and i was surprised to hear
if it was in your film or just if i read
somewhere that there have been lots of
prison revolts uh even in the past few
years and we
you know this one was one i was
maybe 15 when this happened and i
remember hearing about it but i didn't
know much about it and i
really appreciated learning about what
the
the impetus behind it was um
and i know stanley you said you wanted
to
make this film for a long time and it's
the 50th anniversary was that what
propelled you or what prompted you to
make it now um
what was it
i i think you know like so many people i
knew the broad outlines of it um what
was never talk
about as far as i i knew what had
happened was kind of why
the the prisoners had rebelled why they
had taken over the prison
almost like well of course they're not
happy
they're they're in jail you know and so
it it didn't really ever go beyond that
uh veneer but and i had thought about it
you know maybe 20 or 30 years because i
you know wanted to know what happened
and really wanted it to be wanted to
understand um but i think as time went
on i realized that that the the guys in
the yard you know the former prisoners
you know getting older and and this was
probably the less best chance of getting
them um you know a good number of them
uh while their their stories were we're
still in intact and that um you know
once we started filming uh as tracy can
tell you you know the the the the words
just poured out of them it was almost
like they were waiting you know just for
in many cases for somebody to to ask
them and talk to them uh about what had
happened
yeah i i i thought it was great that you
got so many of them and then the
journalists that were there to cover it
and and you know the guy that worked for
rockefeller
were did you approach any of the guards
the former guards or any of them still
around
oh yeah absolutely i mean our goal
starting out was to really tell a 360
degree
um story and talk to all of the people
that were touched by this i've said a
lot of times that this film um the story
of attica is a lot like that parable of
blind men in the elephant where
depending on what part of it you touched
um it really kind of colored and
informed your experience of it so i
certainly um spent as much time trying
to reach out to the guards
and also former civilian employees who
were hostages um as the prisoners i got
in contact with about five of them
um had extensive conversations with
three um all of whom had agreed to be in
the film um and i talked to them over
the course of last year just like the
prisoners and the families um and
ultimately a couple of days before we
were gonna film they all decided not to
be in the film so
wow yeah that's interesting well and
they're but their families did which
actually which was very helpful and yes
to getting perspective yeah because it
wasn't
that we sort of tell the story of attica
not just the prison but help people to
understand that this was a community um
in a place
before um it was a prison and you really
kind of need to understand that in order
to really make sense of the dynamics of
what was happening
with race inside the prison
absolutely the prisoners talk about the
beat down police and the horrible
conditions they were compelled to live
in um people have just seen the film but
can you discuss a little bit about the
specifics of
what they were enduring i mean i know
they were treated
inhumanely
and i know the role of toilet paper and
all of that but uh more specific
specifics would be great
yeah tracy you want to answer that
yeah i mean
you hear sort of the prisoners
articulate what is a really kind of um
sophisticated um call for for reform in
the prison i mean there were the
sanitary things that you hear them talk
about like the toilet paper the showers
um there were also labor demands attica
was a prison where if you were an
able-bodied person you had to work that
continues to be true by the way at
attica to this day i mean what also
continues to be true is that they make
pennies um and so one of those demands
was for minimum wage um it was a place
where all of the mail was censored um
it was read and then censored and
because there were no spanish-speaking
guards if you got mail in a language
other than english then it just got
thrown away um
the muslim person is not able to
practice their um their religion openly
there was no imam at the president so
there were demands for religious
intolerance so it really was um you know
an articulation by the prisoners of kind
of the full-scale reforms that they
wanted to see that to this day
a lot of people are still not um able to
to enjoy those rights those rights in
prison
yeah i mean i think that that it's
important that the you know indignities
you know and the horrors were small
scale like getting only one roll of
toilet paper a month which is small
scale of the way but it's pretty
you know major in until
the huge um
uh acts that were happening to them you
know the beat downs and the other things
and if as they say in the film if they
reported um anything or or tried to
complain they were retaliated against
i was shocked to hear that attica is
still
open and and and still has prisoners in
it because i would have thought after
something like that that would you would
close it um
yeah i think i think the thing that
really comes through in the film is that
that you know attica has a character you
know it's just such a creepy place you
know it's it's like you know these 30 40
30 or
40 foot walls you know um the people
talk about you know they coming over a
hill and just seeing it there like oh my
god you know what what is this place
it almost you know it almost like looks
like there should be a moat around it in
a and a drawbridge you know like think
you know
so i mean it's just like you know an
imposing horrible place and it's still
it's still there
and you know people are still imprisoned
i was
you were able to get so much archival
footage which i thought was really
powerful and even you know the the
recordings of nixon
um being pretty damn racist and a big
surprise and you know the conversations
he had with rockefeller and all of that
um where those was i mean that must have
been quite a process
in compiling all of that
uh yeah i mean one of the things
i've done a number of historical films
and and that we try to do from the first
day is to find all the archival footage
is that we possibly can and we go from
the first day you know to to the last
day um that you you know
it's really an interesting piece but but
so many times you know the things that
we see on tv are you know uh the news
director says oh oh you know the
anniversary of attica is coming up in a
week you know pull some clips and we see
the same clips over and over again and
nobody has really taken the time or the
effort to kind of really dig and try to
find you know everything that we
possibly uh
that possibly could could be found and
uh you know we found a lot of in just
incredible stuff i mean it's hard for me
to even describe the archival i mean all
i can say we people have seen it or i
can say you gotta see the film to
believe uh the archival footage and
stills
all the conversations between nixon
how hard was it to find the former
prisoners you found so many people that
just had such powerful recollections was
that that seems like that would be an
arduous process as well
yeah and in some ways it was um odd to
say but it was helped by the pandemic in
the sense that you know i like all of us
was kind of in my little pandemic work
box um but it really gave me the time
and space to spend um not only finding
people but having conversations and
cultivating um those relationships one
of the things that was really helpful um
as far as the prisoners was concerned
was when uh they got their settlements
in 2000 the judge who oversaw the
distribution of that money allowed every
single surviving prisoner to come into
his courtroom and talk as long as they
wanted about what had happened to them
on september 13th 1971 or call in over
phone and there's a transcript of that
um so i spent a lot of time reading
through that and trying to you know
figure out 20 years after that who might
still be around who seemed to have a
compelling um story and then just sort
of systematically went about um
contacting every single person um that i
could and as you can imagine it wasn't
something that everybody was jumping to
kind of revisit with a stranger over the
phone um it was a profound tragedy for
every single person um and a trauma for
every single person that experienced it
and that goes from the prisoners to the
families to also the media everybody um
that that this has touched uh
it kind of sticks with them um so you
know there were some people that weren't
willing to but fortunately for us there
were enough people who were i'm really
courageous and gracious enough um to
sort of sit with me and and talk about
it and and go back there for us
yeah i mean i think one of the central
things is that is that tracy gave people
a space to to you know either
participate or not you know um we just
want to talk and you know if you want to
do it then then then great um one of the
things we didn't want to do is the thing
that producers are so great at you know
trying to convince people to talk you
know to say oh yeah you know it's going
to be really good for you to open up you
know and tell your story because it
might not be good for people to open up
and tell their story so we wanted to
kind of lay out what we wanted to do
and let people make the choice and give
them the space you know to make the
choice
and what did you hear from that
obviously that we made this in 2020 so
there was the extra sort of um allowing
people to say no because there's a
pandemic and they might not be
interested in you know understandably
coming to do a shoot with us so it
really was just kind of allowing people
to space for whatever you know felt
comfortable for them
and what did you hear after they
revisited that did you hear like did it
feel cathartic to some of them what you
know what was the kind of feedback you
got from the prisoners after they did go
and talk about it with you
um well i'll say and stanley can talk
about this too because at this point i
think most if not all of them have seen
the film
um so i i don't want to speak for them
but the sense that i got is that um
having the the space and the platform
and the in this level of visibility um
to talk about to tell the truth about
what happened
um i don't know that they would say it
feels like justice for them but maybe
something close to it um when something
so
um horrible happens to you when you're
harmed by your own government in the way
that all these people were um it does
scar you um and it just kind of is an
open wound for a lot of them and so i
think um being able to talk about it and
having the recognition um and the
understanding of so many people about
their experience through the film feels
something close to um the justice that
none of them got
yeah i mean and you know we had a
screening at the apollo theater in in
new york um
where we brought a lot of the uh
former prisoners and others to it and um
uh you know we had a a psychotherapist
there
there um
and who has worked a lot with with
prisoners and um you know we announced
and began the film that you know she'll
be in the back of the room if anybody
you know wants to talk and a couple of
people did um i think that that um
that a bunch of people were really um
emotionally affected by seeing the film
you know by seeing it cut together by
seeing
you know um
their testimony but but the footage
again um they were you know um in in so
many ways i mean you can imagine i mean
for for
uh just regular audiences when we show
them the film i mean they're just
shocked you know many times people come
up to us and like ah i'm just speechless
but if you can imagine you know that
that was your life and seeing it there
um
you know and we've tried to to work with
the former prisoners and everybody uh as
much as we can um you know after we've
made the film
yeah so many of them were so young at
such an impressionable time in their
lives too i mean that
stood out when you saw you know the age
they're at now 50 years later
um
i i was struck by when someone said you
know
we didn't get justice all we got was
money and
even then it took 30 years to get that
what was the reason for that long delay
um i don't think the state of new york
was uh
necessarily jumping to um a acknowledge
the harm that was done by the state or
to offer any kind of restitution um to
those people and and for the families um
i mean for the prisoners it was this
25-year legal fight with lawyers pretty
much for free um worked all that time
because they were so personally
passionate about it um but the families
essentially signed away any of their
legal rights to sue the state when they
signed their workman's comp checks
unbeknownst to them um and so they
essentially had to do a public relations
campaign to shame the state of new york
into
uh giving them that settlement but i
think the state was just going to make
it as difficult as possible for any of
these people to get any kind of justice
or or restitution for what was done to
them
so the money went to the surviving
prisoners and then the families of the
ones that had passed away
um yes yeah
yes first over all those people i'm
guessing that was not
it wasn't very much the judge
established cat uh classes of harm um
until frank big blacksmith obviously um
experienced horrific horrific torture
and so he was sort of the worst um and
so it went from there down to just sort
of you know the basic torture that they
all experienced and there were different
levels that sort of dictated um what
amount of money but but yes by that time
i mean most of them were very um old men
at that point and um it you know 12
million sounds like a lot but 4 million
went to the lawyers and then once you
kind of disburse it amongst all those
people it wasn't
a huge amount of money
right
of that scene those scenes where you see
them being forced to walk naked with
their hands on their heads and
beaten and forced and talking about
being forced to walk through broken
glass i mean it really does feel
reminiscent of slave markets and just
incredible
horrific cruelty it's
shocking
that there was footage of it too
yeah i mean i i think one of the the
great things for us as filmmakers was
that there were pictures and that there
was footage you know i mean they can
tell you about it and and and you know
obviously um they tell you about it you
know emotionally and they're great but
um when they tell you about it and you
see it at the same time
you know um i think that that's just
incredible and and it's it's so
interesting because for everybody in so
many ways that's the most shocking you
know part of
and um you know what i what i started
trying to do is is talk to people about
the the also the roller coaster ride
that that the film is so that the the
end of the film is so devastating it
just sticks with you but also to
remember that that that this started out
and and they talk about the fact that
you know that they
that things were going to change and
they were going to win and and that you
know it might
start
making people look at the whole prison
system in a different way and then that
the devastating uh wait wait
so i think that's important that we
remember you know back to the beginning
of the film
where there you go
i love that you showed it day by day
because you did you had hope
as you're watching especially if you're
not familiar with it if you're a younger
person or whatever and you think okay
maybe some reform can come of this this
you know and then
the yeah roller coaster ride is a
perfect way to describe it
i mean it was so much worse than what
you not only you know did they
you know get held for
you know the fact that they did it but
then they were tortured on top of
everything else
uh and then you think well at one point
was it oswald who you know said yes to
28 of their 30 demands so you think you
know you do have some element of hope
yeah i mean you know i
obviously they were close i mean they
they were very close you know
um if rockefeller had come up you know
and and and just stood outside and
showed some concern
um
would it have ended in a different way i
definitely would have ended in a
different way i you know who knows
exactly how it would have ended but but
it it they you know it was the amnesty
the whole thing really where they
centered around around you know the uh
the demand for amnesty
and the fact that rockefeller
uh continued to ferment those lies and
that that
prisoners had actually hurt the hostages
and didn't acknowledge the fact that it
was all done by any
any uh
injury or killing was done by law
enforcement
uh it really
i didn't know very much about
rockefeller but it certainly paints him
in an absolutely terrible light um
that just
it's beyond the pale that he would you
know wanting to continue those lies
despite i wondered also about the the
two prisoners who were convicted of
killing william quinn the guard
uh are they still serving time what
happened with
them um so i actually spoke with one of
them um
going to be in film um he also kind of
ultimately declined but he's been out um
for a while i'm not sure what happened
to to the other person but um yeah one
of them is out he's just kind of you
know living his life
were they just eroded i mean how did
they how did
that happen yeah i mean to um
hear the attorneys tell it um the the
the way that he there were so many
people that were involved in the assault
that no one person could really be
identified um who did it um and so the
attorneys kind of feel like that was an
unjust
prosecution
um
but i think you know the state was going
to have to get its town a flesh from
from somebody um and these two guys
happen to be happy to be those two
people so
i wanted to ask you also about was it
called the observation committee
um
observers committee right um
sort of how that
happened and and how it uh you know
talking to those folks how that process
went
yeah i mean i i think that that you know
what what has to to be clear is that for
you know for the first 48 hours or so
you know the prisoners were really in
charge i mean they had hostages as they
say and you know that that was the
difference between attica and so many uh
other uh prisoner business that they had
hostages
and uh and so they
uh
as the prisoners got together and we we
talked about how other persons united
and they they voted on on who their
leaders should be and one of the
the first things that they asked for was
that one the press come in so that so
that the press could see everything that
that was happening and and that's you
know one reason why the footage is so
incredible you know because they invited
the president and they were there
filming everything um
and two that that they have an observer
committee who would come in and and
observe the negotiations that that went
on uh and those were people uh of the
prisoners choosing uh and they were
chosen for a lot of different reasons
but they were people who would who had
uh worked in the prison system who had
written about prison system uh john dunn
was head of uh i forgot what it's called
some prison committee uh in the senate
and uh you know so they they chose those
people um and then as you see in the
film um they really became
negotiators much more than just
observers they were negotiating for the
for for the business and maybe that's
partially because you know as we show on
i believe it's the second day uh russell
oswald the prison commissioner in new
york leaves and doesn't come back
yeah i think
the observers um were sort of their own
narrative within the narrative and kind
of the journey that they took because so
many of them came in
not quite understanding what their role
was going to be um that they could maybe
help in some way or listen and like
stanley said it became clear to them
that that oh we are we are an integral
part of this process that these these
men are relying upon us to be their
their voice um to help them negotiate
this with
the prison and we were so fortunate that
we were able to get clarence jones i
mean as you see it kind of
he kind of speaks for himself um the
greatness of who he is in that film but
he really is kind of the moral
center i think the moral heart of the
film and his his perspective and his
take on it i think just kind of cuts
through
um uh and particularly that last kind of
sentiment that he leaves us with that
this is just something that should not
ever
have have has happened um and we're so
fortunate um that we he agreed to to to
be in the film so i think he's just
such a powerful voice in this story
absolutely yeah i mentioned that he's
about to turn 90 and we'll never ever
ever ever forget that was very powerful
yeah um the mark of a really great film
is that it stays with you and haunts you
and that you want to know more and you
know you're ready
what stayed with me afterwards was you
know you talk about the roller coaster
you know uh
like you know
28 of the demands are are being met and
uh maybe and then bobby seals coming and
all these things that are like raising
their hopes and then what ends up
happening and i kept thinking and what
happened afterwards how how badly were
they tortured
afterwards for what they had done it
must have you know
that
there must have been so much following
it did you hear
you know after the whole thing was over
how
you know how they were treated
uh
tracy i mean i mean they they
i just say first the torture didn't end
when we it did it in the film i mean we
just we just couldn't go on and on and
on and we said okay okay you got it you
i mean by the time they're by the time
they're running over over glass with
bare feet and being beaten you know
okay i got it i got you know you got it
but
just you want to give some more yeah
yeah i mean i think you know stanley
felt and so that i that at a certain
point um
you know there's a fine line between uh
uh
the necessary violence that needs to be
shown and getting to a point where it's
kind of gratuitous and you're you know
you're you're asking too much
of the audience um
being in this experience but yeah that
night the torture continued um there
were you know eight men put in a
settlement for one naked standing up all
night there were guards that came and
played russian roulette with them
pulling the trigger into the cell
um over and over again beatings
continued um you know been described
hearing men screaming throughout the
prison and blood on the floors i mean it
goes on and on and on um
there's also sometimes like chasing
someone i just gotta want to add this
one because this is one of my favorites
i mean also just just you know with
eight men in a cell just hosing them
down they're nude and it's you know
middle of september now in new york city
in new york state and they're they hose
them down and so they're so they're wet
and freezing you know and
go on
with what you say
yeah yeah and so eventually a lot of
them ended up getting shipped out of
attica to other prisons because the way
that the system in new york would handle
troublemakers and the prison is that
they just sort of ship you off to the
next place or to the next um
prison but this certainly i mean not
just emotionally but it really continued
to have repercussions on a lot of their
lives one of the men tyrone who you see
in the film um was uh in prison i think
for another decade or two and whenever
he had come up for parole
it would come up that oh you were one of
those those thousand men um that was
involved in attica and it it hurt him um
every single time
and he wasn't necessarily he was just
kind of out he's one of the guys that
was out there i mean most of the guys in
our film weren't people that were at the
leadership table they were just kind of
there
but it continued to reverberate
throughout all of their lives in various
ways i mean for many of them
the the day september 9th through 13th
every year for the last 50 years has
been extremely triggering and traumatic
for them to this day
i can imagine why
wow
i feel like there should be
you know
organizations that that investigate how
prisons are functioning today because we
have such a huge amount of prisoners
obviously the most in the world and what
those conditions are like is there is
there any oversight whatsoever uh it
feels like there is
i mean i i'm not an expert on the prison
system i'm sure there are i mean i know
that there are people that do this work
um that are trying to sort of expose the
reality but i think you know
these prisons are built in these remote
places um behind these walls by design
it's not meant for us to see um what's
going on it's not meant for us to hear
in the voices of the prisoners um
what their experience is and what's
happening to them and so i think it's
one of the reasons why you know i really
hope this phone could be an invitation
for people to ask exactly the question
claudia that you just that you just did
and to really kind of sit with and
grapple with um
the answers to those questions
yeah and i think the prison system in in
our country is is broken in one of the
many things but things that are broken
you know i know at one point a few years
back i was doing something and and i
found out that that you know in
california the the the
the lobbyist for the prison guards you
know was the largest lobby in the state
of california you know and so what
they're lobbying for is for
uh you know no oversight they're
lobbying for more people to be put in
prison you know um i did a story on this
tv show
about a town that just built a prison
you know like on spec you know let's
have a small town in ohio or somewhere
and they just built a prison they built
a state-of-the-art prison and then you
know tried to get prisoners to come to
the town it was a way to provide jobs
and make money you know and and and so
i mean it's an incredibly broken system
but you know obviously there there are
people and a lot of good people are
working to change it
yeah i live in california and i know
there's more money spent in this state
on prisons than there is on education
and i you know of course we all hear
about the prison industrial complex and
for-profit prisons and
i never hear anything good about prisons
ever i mean i so
i you know i would imagine there's
people who are trying to do something
but
it just seems like such a huge task i
feel like your film
and perhaps the 13th also should be
required viewing in terms of you know so
people understand really what it's it's
all about um yeah i mean i i think also
that just just i'm sorry to interrupt
but just to throw in there one of the
things you know in the film that that
you see and maybe it's subtle and or
maybe it's not maybe it's right up front
is is is the humanity you know and the
life and the intelligence of these guys
you know um and and and and that they
are real living uh human beings and and
you know it's not like yeah we have we
say that you know it's like we have a
narrator you know that but but you see
it you know you see it you see it you
see it over again and and i get louder
yeah i hope
hopefully it makes people think about
you know the other two million people
who are in prison
oh absolutely yeah that's a really good
point because other films that have been
done about prisons tend to be you know
talking heads and people with good
intentions sociologists psychologists
weighing in but to actually hear the
prisoners and to for them to acknowledge
we realize we did the crime we have to
serve the time
but you know why why are we being
treated like dogs why can't we be
treated like human beings why can't we
practice our religion like you know all
those things which
you know are of course fair and and
you know even though the white guy who
acknowledged that he got special favors
and was you know sheepish about it um i
you know i it was everyone's honesty
really came through loud and clear
um
we've reached our our end of our time
here but this thank you so much for this
really really compelling and important
film stanley i've been a fan of your
films for a long time so it's a real
honor to get to speak with you and tracy
it's lovely to meet you and i can see
how much hard work you did on this so
thank you on behalf of film independent
and just thank you for all of us for for
making this amazing film
[Music]
you